pour commencer comment l'avez vous pris
cette décision on ne portait pas du tout
de maquillage en ce moment c'est bien ça
oui j'ai le sentiment que de nos jours
énormément de fil doivent se maquiller
pour s'intégrer se sentir mais je pense
que la véritable beauté et sousse
maquillage ça alors je pense qu'on peut
encourager toutes les femmes de
simplement se libérer de ne pas se
maquiller se sentir bien dans leur peau
c'est mathieu mais comme dit mon amie
fanny ardant ce siècle oui c'est mon ami
se signalent dans ce ton ami absolument
oui elle te connais fagnières bah oui on
survit pas arrêter de douter tout le
temps quand même alors c'est une très
grande comédienne français oui bah je ne
sais où il donne un film de fanny rares
et de manière non
oui mesdames douce voix de la douce sur
balles à la [ __ ] douce
une amie j'embrasse réalisait ce siècle
n'est plus le mien voilà bientôt le les
concours de beauté on va dire la plus
moche c'est à peu près ce qu'on va faire
maintenant le maquillage et les
chirurgies on enlève tout il faut être
beau peu importe comment nous voilà
c'est ridicule sinon nous venons ici
aussi sans maquillage on va 31 comme
raymond
[Rires]
moi je suis pas du tout d'accord dans le
2e je suis désolé c'est sinon c'est
venez comme vous êtes comme chez mcdo
venir sans maquillage chez n'importe
quoi je pense que tout le monde attend
justement que les gens viennent avec un
peu d'extravagance du bon maquillage des
belles tenues tout simplement des belles
coiffures des belles boucles comme moi
par exemple voilà tout simplement c'est
ça ça va bien si l'on
ait la même palette va du beige book bin
ça mon fils y sava vrai parce que comme
il a dit mathieu sinon on venons tous
comme ça sans make-up alors il faut
créer un autre concours miss naturels
jouets raymond ça peut mettre tout le
monde à égalité aussi oui oh pas se
maquiller le fait d'arriver comme comme
tu dis comme vous êtes ça peut être ça
peut mettre tout le monde est hypocrite
on crée on n'a pas tout dépend ce que
c'est le maquillage qui le différencie
attend pas dormir alors que oui il ya
bien sûr que oui il vient semble alors
je les genres maillot cet été alors il
n'y a pas que ça qui vous différencie il
est magnifique
c'est une très bonne idée les concours
comme miss france ne servent à rien à
part à complexer des millions de femmes
qui ne se sentent pas à la hauteur trop
petit trop grosse pas une assez belle
peau las envoie un message très fort ce
qu'il faut c'est vrai que c était comme
mon
fils que ce soit sur instagram ou dans
la vraie vie justement tu me fais rire
en parlant de vous cette année dans
avait fait un petit soin du visage oui
avenue avenue trith non non oui c'est
vrai pour ma part mais c'est vrai j'ai
passé un très bon c'est vrai mais ce
qu'on m'a dit bah voilà votre peau
magnifique merci oui femmes petits soins
du visage et là est le petit soin à 300
balles c'est pas comme tout le monde non
mais c'est pas pareil c'est mon épiderme
je suis un homme a regardé avait fait
voir aux mains regarder en direct dit
l'ophone
we can i moi je pense qu'on fait parler
des sommes clairement hypocrite parce
que je pense que vous êtes bien content
quand les femmes se pouponner se font
belles pour vous déjà si une meuf un
soir à la rive au restaurant et qu'elle
ait des maquillée habillée en plein
match pense pas que ça va te plaire on
compte en était en handi peau
contrairement à panama ils étaient
ensemble on n'a pas dit le combat que je
voulais dire qu'on nous donne la
possibilité ensemble on a passé l'été
ensemble mais je suis désolé j'ai pas
attirés par les meufs démaquillant dis
pas qu on dit pas qu une femme maquillée
on dit pas qu une femme acquiesce c'est
pas joli aussi si elle veut passer le
concours sans être maquillée et si elles
gagnent douala en demi finale si elle
gagne la finale tant mieux si elle a
gagné pas maquillée contre rennes qui
arrivent et transpirante dégueulasse
avec soldat louis me faire croire que l
océan de ménage souplesse m'a parlé
du tour avec mon amie simone faire
croire qu'on va encore jugé les miss
pour ce qu'elles ont à l'intérieur
vous
compensez téléspectateurs parce que j
avais oui à 60 wi
fi démago s'économise qui me regardait
rareté à 80 % les pertes un regard c'est
vrai